we talk about alien routing and talk and
now I'd like to address the prickly
subject of hidden services my a cave a
dark web
so max has done a good video on dark web
and so you should definitely watch that
one first so you know what it is but
it's quite a controversial topic because
a lot of what happens on the dark web is
illegal right there's no two ways about
it very some of it isn't right and a lot
of what happens on tour in general in
fact the majority of what happens on
tool in general you know high into the
90% and that and above is perfectly fine
right it's just anonymous users browsing
the web doing regular things but the tor
hidden services are ones that but the
debate is about because they're the ones
where you sort of say well is it worth
this bit of encryption is it worth you
know all the criminality boots on there
and so on so here's my cloud might or
cloud and in essence we've got lots of
people going into the network a lots of
encrypted layers and things happening
bouncing around and then people coming
out to the network to servers right now
the issue with security standpoint is
what happens if there's someone sniffing
here and someone's sniffing here and
they can correlate traffic between the
in and the out and work out what it is
that I am doing specifically right then
the whole report the whole point of tor
which is anonymization has been defeated
right we already have encryption so that
isn't the point of talk but just how
they do beyond the anonymous
communication so the dark web or a
hidden service as to use the proper term
is in essence where this server moves
inside this cloud right so now we have a
hidden service running inside this cloud
and there is no B that's the idea right
so it makes it very very difficult to
find so there is now a circuit that goes
somewhere between a around the place to
this hidden service and at no point has
that left the network so there's no
traffic correlation that can be done
right all of these are just tore sale
messages but we look exactly the same
now the wave it taught does this is very
very clever and I look I will look into
a little bit of detail on the protocol
but it uses but it's managed to form a
protocol
we're neither I nor the server know who
each other are but we can still have a
conversation which is kind of nifty okay
Clevedon let's start again with line Li
mu T so Onion Routing is a protocol that
could theoretically be implemented
elsewhere there's other mixing networks
and things and other anonymization
networks but hidden services is put on
predominately the domain of tour and
tours got the most users and the most
nodes and it's the biggest and is in the
news the most let's draw a little bit of
a network again so I shouldn't have
drawn these boxes like this because now
it takes me ages so here's my server
here's my client and these I'm just
going to drawn with boxes because I've
always going to take far too long either
Onion Reuters so remember in normal
Onion Routing the client will produce
some circuits or some hops and then they
will just talk to the server but a
server will be out on the normal web
doing normal server things and won't be
anonymous what hidden services do is
anonymize this server so they allow both
the server and the client to talk to
each other despite the fact that no one
knows who each other is which is quite
impressive now of course if you then use
that service connection to log in you're
going to know you are but you get the
idea the server has to lay some
groundwork down before a client connects
use a hidden service right so there's
protocols in the tor specification for
doing this but what the server will do
when they come online is they will pick
three onion routers at random and name
them as introduction points so let's
pick them at random now these are just
normal onion routers they're very likely
to be just doing regular normal routing
tasks like circuits through other
clients into servers and things some of
these might be exit nodes entry nodes
and so on but as far as I know all onion
routers can also act as introduction
points it's not a big job I didn't
require a huge amount of bandwidth the
server will make connections circuits to
these introduction points they've either
full on tour circuits with three hops in
between them the idea being that these
introduction points know they're going
to be introducing people to this server
but they don't know who it is why it's
already the server is hiding behind a
layer of anonymity here it will send
them a message to say I'd like you to
act as an introduction point and then it
will create something called a server
hidden service descriptor which I was
write down here that will include the
service public key for
occasion purposes but I won't dwell on
that particularly but also crucially the
IP addresses of these introduction
points here now these are all public
anyway they will publicly listed now it
will publish this descriptor to
something called a distributed hash
table that is to say all of the routers
on tor will hold some in some part of
the information on all of these hidden
services and the idea is that if I try
and look up a hidden service the roots
are responsible for it will give me back
the descriptor by including the
addresses over the introduction points
now the key for this hash table is the
onion address right so the onion dress
that everyone knows about is actually
derived from the public key of this
server and is in essence the key but
gets these IPS out of the distributed
hash table the whole point of this is
that the onion address isn't publicized
on the global Tor network
you just find it other ways like on a
net on an internet or your friend tells
you or in an email or something like
this the waiver the distributed hash
table is programmed the vast majority of
nodes won't know what the description is
for a given key I only want more
probably or couple so there's an
inherent security here
it doesn't until recently it's also made
it quite difficult to work at how many
hidden services there were so this is
all set up now the server sits there and
waits for Internet connections or people
to ask for a web web file now and these
onion routers these IPS the introduction
points just sit there being in being
normal routed and waiting here me I want
to connect to this hidden service and
someone gave me the onion address so
that's really what I need so what I do
is I request the descriptor off the hash
table and it gives it back that has the
three IP and I pick one at random right
let's say this top one here what I'm
going to do in essence the short version
is I'm going to ask this IP to introduce
me to a server and then we're going to
meet in the middle at someone debut
point that's the idea
so let's work out how it works I've sort
of run out of colors so I'm going to go
over the orange pen here it's a bit
bright I choose a rendezvous point at
random and I create a tour circuit to
that rendezvous point
remember that essentially all of these
arrows are the full connections this one
has two hops on it not three because the
rendezvous point is a third hop so it
goes on like this now I send a message
to the one
7-point saying I'd like you to introduce
me to the server by this introduction
point and I want you to send it the word
cookie right now that could be any
string it's not important the point is
sort of like a one-time password kind of
thing to verify but no one else has got
involved in this conversation the
rendezvous point creates a circuit to
this IP and sends it the word cookie it
also sends its own address because of
course this doesn't know it because the
circuit and we need to be at a
rendezvous here so this IP forwards the
cookie on to the server and at this
point the server can either accept it
and decide to try and make a connection
or do nothing right so you can imagine a
situation where instead of a cookie some
kind of special password but you need to
be able to connect to this website and
the server just does nothing that's
that's one thing that could happen right
they have an authentication token I
think but at this point the introduction
points job is done there is no more
these would be the serve their purpose
all they do is forward the cookie onto
the server right bear in mind we don't
know where it is and eat the server
decides whether it's going to connect
let's assume because otherwise this will
be a much shorter video that the server
does want to talk said he to the
rendezvous point so it creates another
circuit I don't know how many 1 2 3 4 5
but at 5 we've got six circuit right
across the Tor network to the one David
point which is the cookie of the wrong
very important details yes that
rendezvous point details will be well it
be attached to the same message with the
cookie and yes good question now the
server sends the one they've appoint a
rendezvous please essentially message
weave the cookie in it and the mod
labelled point looks at these two
cookies and goes well I was requested of
one they blew by this guy with this
cookie I've received a connection from
some server also with the cookie they
must be talking about each other right
that's the idea it could be doing lots
of on the moves at the same time with
different cookies and it will then act
as just another hop on this network and
connect these two up so this comes over
here like this and this comes down here
and they kind of get bridged by this
rendezvous point here convened on the
rendezvous point acts like a normal
onion mu 2 and just decrypt messages
passes them out the other side like
always so for anyone that's sort of lost
count there are at least six hops here
right there two intermediate node
on this circuit then the rendezvous
point in three intermediate nodes on
this circuit right it's just part of the
protocol that there's only two this side
that's obviously going to be quite a lot
slower than normal talk these could be
all over the world like this it's going
to take quite a long time but there is
no real way of getting in on this
conversation right if you're sniffing
here or sniffing here all you're seeing
is encrypted tor cells all of 512 bytes
long jumping around this place she's got
no idea what any of them are right very
very difficult to track that's why it's
so difficult to find hidden services
okay because they're hidden yeah kind of
the point they wouldn't have couldn't
they did something else no they did in
term they didn't name it incorrectly to
say sometimes were vulnerabilities found
in the protocol right or compromised
knows which allow hidden services to be
found this happened for example Silk
Road - but that's not that common right
and there's the bigger the network gets
the more beautiful no combinations are
the heart of that process gets now as an
aside some servers don't need anonymity
and this many hops is too slow all right
so they want to protect their clients
but they don't care about but if people
know who they are Facebook for example
so Facebook work foot-tall recently to
introduce something called single onion
in that case the only difference is the
bit server doesn't bother with these
three hops it just goes straight to the
rendezvous point now that obviously
forgoes servers anonymity because the
one living point knows what it is
but it takes a puppy we know whether
servers are I think right so they don't
mind about that their business is
protecting their customers they don't
care but we know where their servers are
so that's an alternative and you it's
quite a lot faster because you've
removed three possibly global hops from
there what benefit is that Facebook -
you know some of just using a normal
sort connection Facebook there's a small
chance if you're using a normal tor
connection that some will be sniffing
here and sniffing here and do traffic
correlation and work out what's going on
right there's no chance about happening
when it's a hidden server it never
leaves the Tor network that's the thing
if you imagine that cloud you're talking
to Facebook entirely inside that cloud
very hard to get in but on the other
hand
Facebook server location is actually
known because if you were operating the
rendezvous point and Facebook said we'd
like to connect back to the
client you'd immediately know that
because it's Facebook's server so it's
like a halfway compromise and I think a
fairly reasonable compromise so it's
Facebook putting one foot inside the
cloud yeah yeah one foot inside did to
talk loud with messages encrypted once
with k3 it's encrypted another time with
k2 and when it's encrypted a final time
with k1 now let's think about what that
means it means that only this routes are
here